so far in the course we've been studying
the motion of collections of particles
we would now like to consider rigid
bodies
now rigid bodies can be translated in
space as I move it like this or we can
rotate this rigid body about some point
I can rotate it about the end point I
can rotate it about a point which recall
we called the center of mass so I can
rotate it about the center of mass I can
take the rigid body and I can rotate it
about the center of mass and also
translate it in space so there's many
types of motions that we can do with
rigid bodies sometimes the motions are
quite complicated if I spin it like that
it is a very more complicated motion you
can see that it's rotating about this
axis so what we'd like to do now is
analyze how to think about the motion of
rigid bodies and what we'd like to do is
idealize our rigid body so let's just
draw even though we looked at a rod here
let's just draw some extended idealized
rigid body and let's identify two points
in that rigid body the J point and the K
point and we'll have think of our rigid
body as a bunch of point-like particles
MJ and MK and the important thing that
defines a rigid body is the condition
that the distance and we'll draw this a
vector from the cape particle to the J
the particle so we'll draw that as our j
k and actually i would like to write it
from the k particle to the j particle r
KJ and our condition is that the
magnitude of this vector which will
denote as r KJ is constant for all
points
J and K now what does that mean that
means the distance between any two
points in the rigidbody stays fixed no
matter how the rigid body is moving and
no matter what two points I choose the
distance between any two points is fixed
so we'll rewrite this as the distance
between any two points
is fixed so that doesn't change and
that's what we call the rigid body
condition